a cop's job is to identify a crime to
take that person into custody and to
take them to before a judge and to have
them processed for the crime they're not
there to administer punishment I think
that's where the problem with some cops
get some cops get so
somebody spits on your face it's hard
not to react yeah
I've had that my name is Brad white my
name tag said be white when I worked in
South Central I had a guy actually come
up to me and we were involved in a
scenario where I was investigating crime
and he noticed my name tag and he
decided to go on a tangent about it I
see how it [ __ ] is Officer B white
you know and didn't even register with
me but I'm like oh [ __ ] no my name is
Brad man you know my name is Brad dude
right you're missing the rad part yeah
yeah dude I I actually got my name tag
changed because of it I just didn't want
to deal with that sure yeah I just
didn't want to deal with that anymore
sure dude people want to go to bed at
night and close their eyes and feel
they're safe that's the only reason we
all sleep at night because we think
there's people out there that are
keeping us safe you know there is a
that's a really good point isn't it it
is the second that the police are gone
somebody in your house is going to have
to be at your window which is the
craziest part of what's going on lately
it's hard to watch I've escaped it you
know even after Rodney King there was a
push and I'm down for the push I'm down
for everything always getting better we
can in any in any facet we can get
better we can do this better but this is
a very complex job that you can't
you can't identify everything you're
going to come in in contact with there's
no way to be ready for everything that
happens no there's just no possible way
in this job right and
a large portion of these things that
you're coming in contact with are life
and death you know their their moment
they're they're brutal some of the best
people I've ever met were cops yeah just
really saw and we came from all
different places yeah there is a lot of
guys that you see you know like they
probably got their ass kicked through
high school and became cops
but I found the majority of those guys
they were good dudes there was guys that
weren't you know but within police
departments especially now they really
police themselves and and contain or get
rid of those people they don't want that
either police departments are staffed by
people from the community they go
through a hiring process and they get oh
yeah we get everything and this is a
good example of people judging the cops
based on the actions of one person or a
dozen or so we actually at my Police
Department had two different cops one I
worked with forever one I knew right off
the bat that were child molesters damn
that we found out they were talking as a
matter of fact the one officer that um
that we caught the first one he molested
the son of one of our other officers
they were best friends so again you're
talking about a situation where the
world goes we can't even have one bad
cop well [ __ ] we're with you on you know
not right we're with you but we're also
this piece of a piece of society we're
dealing with it too yeah you know we're
dealing with it too as soon as we find
out that it's there I mean we we
obviously this guy was gone in prison
and we we handled that situation a lot
of cops were just really solid solid
human beings and and the world just
recently they tried to turn on them in
their entirety they did exactly what
they said that the uh that is happening
to other people they completely
stereotyped a million people yeah it's
crazy right right they yeah it's like
people saying don't stereotype but then
we're gonna stereotype this huge group
of people that are keeping us safe and
now we're less safe than we've ever been
are we really I was going to ask you
that are we less safe than we've ever
absolutely the whole idea of police work
when I started the whole idea of police
work in its entirety was proactive
policing man get out there and find
crime before it occurs I want you to
shake cars I want you to shake cars
means pull them over find out what's
going on find out what they got up there
I want you to Frisk tickle yes and
there's a whole dynamic to that that's
always in debate of like oh he stopped
me because of this or he stopped me
because of that which is it's it's
really not true but it's too long of an
explanation for that but the whole idea
of police work was is to find the crimes
before they occurred and now what has
happened with what the demonizing of
police and the way that they have
unfairly attacked them like I said the
expectation is of oh man he only had a
baseball bat and you shot him right you
know it's like what are you talking
about like this wasn't even a
conversation that was stomped down back
in the day that wasn't allowed to go
very far because that's ridiculous right
but now guys are losing their jobs
they're not just losing their jobs
they're going to jail so now literally I
still have my a good friend of mine is
the chief of the police department that
I worked at now and they're literally
telling police officers and essentially
I only want you to deal with what we
have to deal with so cops aren't out
there doing proactive policing anymore
they're not out there actively looking
for stuff because they're literally
scared that no matter what they do the
world's going to turn on them based on
a video clip the concerted push of
demonizing a million people
and we we've never really we have done
that but we don't really do that to any
other profession like we do cops I've
had women
that look like mothers
completely lose their [ __ ] on me wow
just over a ticket just completely
unreasonable screaming yelling cussing
don't you got anything [ __ ] better to
do you know there's crimes going on and
yeah and that's just such an ignorant
statement to you know we have to enforce
all laws you know there's reasons all
laws are in place most cops are cynical
and calloused and there's a [ __ ]
reason for it man because you spend 20
30 years of going and dealing with the
world [ __ ] every single day you really
start getting convinced
world's [ __ ] up man this is a bad
place this world to me is tough this
world is ugly this world you don't like
I said you don't know what's behind this
door cops every day get invited into
people's homes Uninvited yeah you you
have never been in the home besides a
party where people didn't want you there
we would go every day into people's
homes that didn't want us there and they
had no choice so every day we're walking
into environments that normal people
don't go into and is it weird right when
you walk in like where do you stand in
the room that's what I always feel like
sometimes I'm looking at costume like it
always seemed like I don't know where
like would I stand here would I stand
here it's it's there's so much training
even in that aspect as far as tactical
advantage and how you stand gun leg back
you know always being they teach you to
watch I went to so many Behavior
Analysis class uh courses where they
would teach you based on the way people
sit during interviews if they're telling
the truth or the way someone's acting
when they're sitting of what could
possibly occur next and everything's
tactical cops do every everything for a
reason like they 90 of the time they'll
want to bring people out of their home
because that's their environment we
don't know what's in that environment we
don't know what's behind that door yeah
we don't know what's under that couch
cushion so they try to bring them into
the most
um
safe environment they possibly can which
is usually to bring them out of the
house everything a cop does on a call is
all planned it's it's all from training
and there's all a process to it wow yeah
there's a lot there's a lot that people
don't even you know there's a lot to it
I think there's like a million cops in
America there's a million people
what we're talking about let's let's say
a thousand of them are bad people a
thousand of them is it our duty is it
our job as police officers or would to
and to identify those people and get rid
of them absolutely and I got I'm not
here I'm not
advocating for police I I have no
there's no reason for me to right um I'm
being honest with you
I'm not trying to say oh cops or this or
not but you you need to be fair you need
to be fair with cops you know a thousand
are bad
don't go into it with the thought
process that you have don't participate
in what you're seeing you see people
saying you know [ __ ] the police or all
cops are bad or defund the cop you know
find a way
to assist in in that process of going no
you know that's not right these are we
need to identify individuals and we need
to have and people the argument they'll
have is go well we can't have we can't
have one bad cop you know I mean there's
too much power you know we can't have
one bad cop I agree but it's also
[ __ ] impossible it's also [ __ ]
important it's totally unrealistic and
especially a pressure to put on these
people that already have so much
pressure on them yes and it's not really
probably gonna change anything it's just
a bunch of Battle Cry [ __ ] that
doesn't really in the end is it really
changing anything you know it's making
us less safe I think if if someone could
put something together where they just a
cop just came and say hey this is this
is a story and people start hearing that
every day and just going like dude the
world
stuff that's going on in the world right
now you know the stuff that goes on
every day and has always gone on is
always is going to go on I think people
would be a little more understanding of
of the difficulty of the job you know
the difficulty of
policing the world you know and maybe be
a little more less judgmental you know a
little less harsh it's a tough life it's
it's a different life the world doesn't
know what's going on out there you have
no idea what's going on out there I do
yeah it's a hard reality to live with
you guys are expected to handle so much
like some people are mentally unwell
somebody somebody's got a gun somebody's
doing sex traffic and somebody's trying
to hide a kid in their attic you know
it's like you don't [ __ ] know nope
you never know what you're walking into
either many situations where you think
it's one thing and it's something
totally different cops are scared to do
their job
you know they're just scared to do their
job they didn't I can imagine I can't
even imagine yeah the public doesn't
understand you know once when a guy
comes
it's it's difficult to describe but it's
life and death you know cops shouldn't
have to die just because
you know that the people want the fight
to be fair there is no fight here my job
is to get him in custody and take him
before magistrate that's it right and I
gotta do what I gotta do to give me
custody but if this guy's fighting me
the way he is he'll kill I have to I
have to think he'll kill me to get away
I have no choice yeah especially if a
guy that's already killed other people
or done thing you know this is a bad guy
it's not a good guy yes who's here on
the ground it's like this ain't a great
guy yes you know this ain't a guy who's
been doing great stuff or learning
Spanish or something all day this is
somebody who has is been doing crime we
just got to get through this and good
will come of this amen it's unfortunate
you know but good will come of this good
came of Rodney King great things came
from the Rodney King incident it really
I saw it I lived it I watched the change
oh absolutely when I first started there
was a lot of stuff that went on that
slowly I watched it get you know when
you're when you're new you just kind of
stand back I watched it slowly get
eliminated slowly get better things
slowly improve on the way they handle
stuff you know yeah it's it's it's
definitely getting better and and it's
it's gonna get better policing is
completely totally necessary how we how
we do it is just going to continue to
evolve
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one